SCP-096, the Shy Guy, versus SCP-055, the
unknown object.
SCP-055 is an anti-meme, meaning that it’s
impossible to remember any of its properties
after viewing it.
When matched up against SCP-096, an anomalous
humanoid that attacks anything that sees its
face, it’s difficult to say who would come
out on top.
If SCP-055 is alive, and placed in a room
with SCP-096, the Shy Guy would charge forward
with murderous intent, but as soon as it blinks
or looks away, the crazed creature would forget
about what it was running towards entirely.
If SCP-055 is a mere object, SCP-096 would
have little interest in disposing of it, and
the two might be able to coexist in the same
containment chamber peacefully.
Unfortunately, this is a matchup we may never
have a conclusive answer to.
Wait…
What was SCP-096 fighting again?